les habitants des yvelines en deuil
après l'assassinât de samuel patick
professeur d'histoire géographie au
collège du bois d'aulne de conflent des
hommages rendus dans tout le département
en particulier dans la commune du drame
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mes
habitants
nous nous relèverons nous nous
relèverons tous ensemble après plusieurs
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
consécutifs dont un couvre-feu de 21h à
6h du matin le président de la
république
emmanuel macron a finalement annoncé un
recond films en général à compter du 29
octobre 2020 de nombreux magasins jugés
non essentiels ont donc été contraints
de fermer à nouveau leurs portes
jusqu'au 28 novembre
des mesures qui n'ont pas fait
l'unanimité en fait c'est passé avec les
librairies françaises souhaitée c'est
plutôt que nous on ouvre aux librairies
indépendantes ont roues parce qu'on est
tout à fait à même de savoir gérer un
flux de personnes dans une librairie
avec des jauges avec les barrières
sanitaires respecter contraint de rester
chez eux les yvelinois ont adopté la
livraison de colis
les commandes sur internet ont explosé
en témoignent les 35 mille colis par
jour livré sur le périmètre nord des
yvelines ce qui est beaucoup plus que je
contrôle devrait traiter normalement
avec la période de confinement ses
environs plus de 28% par rapport à ce
qu'on avait prévu initialement
après la démission de philippe benassaya
élu député de la 11e circonscription
jean-philippe luce a été nommé pour lui
succéder en tant que maire de bois
d'arcy
il a pris ses fonctions le samedi 7
novembre moi je suis évidemment fier et
ému de pouvoir aujourd'hui devenir mère
et être mère de tous les artisans pour
eux pour ce nouveau mandat
une page se tourne pour l' usine de
renault situé à flins le site
d'assemblage va se transformer en lieu
de recyclage et de reconditionnement
automobile la mutation sera totalement
achevée d'ici à 2024
le téléthon a également été modifié en
raison de l'impossibilité d'organiser
l'événement en présentiel va d'animation
mais de la collecte ainsi que des
programmes numériques
au total huit cent trente six mille
euros de promesses de dons yvelinois ont
quand même été récoltés tout le long du
mois de décembre les yvelines mans
préparer les fêtes de fin d'année de
nombreux tests antigénique ont été faits
avant noël dans les pharmacies une
précaution nécessaire pour retrouver sa
famille dans les meilleures conditions
depuis deux jours j'ai que des résultats
négatifs la semaine dernière les gens
qui venaient en fait ils avaient des
symptômes ils avaient des troubles ils
se poser des questions donc j'avais
5 10% de positif aujourd'hui c'est que
des gens qui veulent se prévenir pour ne
pas être contaminants pendant le dîner
de famille ils ont été reconnus dans la
france entière la famille lefebvre a
remporté la france a un incroyable
talent les huit versailles et ont
émerveillé les français de leurs voix
évidemment nos amis notre entourage et
ou à aimer ce qu'on fait il doit soutenu
mais a surtout eu beaucoup de retours ce
soit en privé ou dans les commentaires
harry découvert cette musique or c'est
un crop je connaissais pas mais si ce
magnifique vous faites donc vraiment
d'avoir fait découvrir cette musique
seuil et plus et des gens c'était
vraiment super content enfin c'est un
beau cadeau de fin d'année pour quatorze
résidents volontaires de l'ehpad mon
repos de sartrouville
l'établissement a accueilli la première
campagne de vaccination yvelinoise
contre la copie 19 le 31 décembre un
événement symbolique pour achever cette
année 2020